economía en directo América de France 24
y me acompaña en el estudio Daniela
Blandón Daniela bienvenida buena mañana
de martes ya estamos pues siguiendo el
curso de la semana qué tal comenzamos en
Francia donde cada vez se escasea más la
gasolina Pues de Raúl muy buenos días
para ustedes una huelga en varias
refinerías de petróleo operadas por
total energis y exxon móvil entró en su
tercera semana y ha desconectado al
menos el 60% de la capacidad de
refinación que hay en este país esto
tiene a un tercio de las estaciones de
servicio de la nación sin combustible y
las pocas que lo tienen lo venden más
caro estas acciones han provocado
enormes filas en las gasolineras al
mismo tiempo los trabajadores agrupados
en la cgt siguen apostados a las afueras
de sus lugares de trabajo esto para
exigir una mejora salarial en medio de
las enormes ganancias de sus empleadores
y de la alta inflación nos piden un
aumento del 10% al menos en su salario
el gobierno se ha declarado listo para
intervenirnos
yo creo que en una primera etapa en
primera instancia hay que darle una
oportunidad a la negociación una
negociación de buena fe y que no se
puede alargar porque nuestros
compatriotas legítimamente están hartos
quieren una solución rápida les debemos
una solución rápida o las negociaciones
comienzan y tienen éxito rápidamente y
los depósitos de combustibles se reabren
o utilizaremos otros medios disponibles
para nosotros Daniela también vamos con
una noticia del día que hemos relatado
nosotros aquí nuestras noticieros porque
Japón reabrió desde hoy las puertas al
turismo sin ningún tipo de restricciones
le gustaría Me encantaría ir a Japón
comer todo el Sushi del mundo
pues durante más de dos años nadie pudo
hacerlo porque Japón implementó
estrictos controles fronterizos para
frenar la pandemia del covid 19
ellos era el límite diario de 50.000
ingresos también volvieron los viajes
sin visa ahora para negocios y turismo a
corto plazo desde más de 60 países la
única exigencia que permanece es que Los
viajeros deben estar completamente
vacunados con un refuerzo o tener una
prueba de pcr negativa dentro de las 72
horas anteriores a las salidas qué es lo
que se espera con esto el gobierno Pues
que los turistas aporten unos 35.000
millones de dólares anuales lo invito a
que escuchemos la felicidad de algunos
de ellos
vengo de España vinimos aquí para
nuestra luna de miel Así que venimos por
turismo estábamos esperando venir a
Japón por más de un año porque estábamos
preparando la boda y estábamos esperando
el último minuto para obtener un boleto
para venir a Japón porque somos
realmente apasionados por el país
estamos por primera vez aquí y muy
felices de poder venir
hace tres años tenemos previsto viajar
aquí
19 teníamos todo reservado y queríamos
volar pero no pudimos y tuvimos que
quedarnos en casa
ahora es el primer día que podemos venir
aquí ya estamos muy muy felices bueno
seguimos en esa Región del Pacífico
porque Nueva Zelanda quiere poner en un
puesto a la contaminación del ganado
Usted sabe que el ganado es uno de los
mayores contaminantes del mundo Raúl y
el gobierno de Justin Garden Busca que
esos gases de efecto invernadero que
causan animales como las vacas cuando
eructan o cuando hacen sus necesidades
sean grabados a partir del 2025 este
impuesto agrícola sería el primero en el
mundo en un país altamente dependiente
de esta actividad le voy a dar cifras
Raúl los productos lácteos incluidos los
que se usan para hacer fórmula infantil
en China son la fuente de ingresos de
exportación más grande de esta nación
una nación en donde hay cinco millones
de habitantes y el doble de vacas 10
millones de vacas además 26 millones de
ovejas y se estiman que todos ellos
producen la mitad de contaminación con
gases de efecto invernadero los
agricultores rápidamente condenaron esta
iniciativa dijeron que las granjas
entonces van a ser reemplazadas por
árboles y les ponen impuestos
lo que queremos que haga el gobierno
ahora es escuchar a los agricultores
Tomar nota de Lo que siente de la
comunidad rural en el plazo de
comentarios hasta diciembre
y reconocer que se han invertido años de
trabajo antes de esta nueva fase y
realmente nos gustaría que pensaran de
nuevo y detenidamente sobre el efecto
que esto tendrá en aquellas comunidades
que se apoyan en las extensas
propiedades de ganado ovino y vacuno y
Naciones Unidas pide extender por un año
el acuerdo para esta exportación de
granos desde Ucrania Dani la primera
petición que hace amirabdullah que es el
coordinador de la iniciativa de la ONU
para los granos del mar Negro es poner
fin a las inspecciones completas de los
barcos que salen para aliviar el retraso
que se ha venido presentando en las
últimas semanas Ucrania ha exportado más
de 6,8 millones de toneladas de cereales
y otros productos alimenticios alrededor
de un tercio de lo que tiene desde que
se abrió un corredor marítimo en julio
pasado pero la ONU dice que las
engorrosas inspecciones hacen más lento
todo este proceso las cuatro partes del
acuerdo que son Rusia Ucrania y los
intermediarios que son Turquía y
Naciones Unidas están negociando
actualmente una posible extensión Más
allá de la fecha límite de este acuerdo
que vence el 19 de noviembre
cifradía nos venimos para Colombia
porque las cifras son los 176.000
millones de dólares que marcaron un
nuevo máximo histórico en la deuda
externa del país alcanzado esta cifra en
julio de este año según el Banco Central
ahora llega al 50,7% del pib que no está
malo si se compara con otros países
Porque si nos vamos para el Reino Unido
es el 100% del río o para Argentina es
el 90% del pib entonces no es tan malo
pero podría estar mejor 176 mil millones
Dani como siempre gracias por la
información más adelante más economía